hello everybody hope they are good
what's going on with Bitcoin could we
see a reversal today well the truth is
that yesterday's CPI came in slightly
hotter than expected came out 3.7
percent instead of 3.6 percent then we
also got the FTX approval from the court
so they can liquidate to marketable they
have those tokens locked for quite some
time so
I don't see that as a problem in the
short term now I knew that Soul was
going to react to it because uh you know
people panic they sell and you can see
here that right after those news goal
released
this happened okay this red candle it's
like a three percent drop in price okay
and then amazingly you can see how price
you know completely retraced that move
and then it will continue to go on
higher so I mean solo affected in the
very short term literally in in the hour
but then they just didn't care and they
push price up okay so uh that's good
news for crypto now of course if you
look at this chart and then one hour
time frame it was good you know because
you have basically broken out of this
Zone okay Judo of the one out of 50 main
but the problem is that if you're going
to the folder time frame right now you
know you are there playing with the 4
hour 50 minutes so why wouldn't long
Solana as long as it doesn't close above
the four or 50 minutes so basically you
want to learn to close above this purple
line
okay and then I will tell you okay yes
you could long it but the problem is
always the same the problem is Bitcoin
why is Bitcoin doing and what are we
anticipating for Bitcoin in the next New
York session well the truth is that this
was a projection okay from seven days
ago and you can see how how Wednesday
okay on Wednesday and Thursday
a bit on kind of continue going up so
this was you know a pump retrace
continuation we filled this week okay
and then you had also here an aggressive
drop right after fill in the week uh 1.6
dropping one hour candle okay now
Bitcoin is continuing going why because
he left
a liquidity pull behind and is this one
over here
okay so far market for you
that's a liquidity pool all right so we
still have to come all the way here to
26 500. probably into this in your
session and if you remember your plan
basically we had this plan okay on
Wednesday we retraced the one hour and
the 4 Hour 50 May fall out if I'm not
wrong hang on
yeah there you go you say there and then
the continuation to the upside but maybe
this could be a slightly add used to
something like this
all right
but
this is the plan that I have for today
okay I'm expecting
a midweek reversal we could probably see
a spike again okay rephrase this
liquidity pool maybe we can break the
high okay so that would be this top hunt
here okay
all the way to 2600 something like that
and then they could see price dropping
from there okay
reversal so uh let me explain to you
again why here so let me remove all of
this
ah by the way yes if you if price breaks
some of the 50 EMA into daily time frame
then uh the shortest scenario is
invalidated okay but that's what I'm
anticipating that maybe we see today a
stop hunt towards the sun yeah 26 700 26
800 even 27k why not all the way to the
50ma and then I drop because if you look
at the weekly cycle
but with the psychological cycle this is
something that I also uh teach the guys
in the course but basically you have the
weekend range
so let's draw it
that's you we can range here
okay then you go Monday's first move
does this drop okay you can see it there
then the weak strength and then on
Thursday sometimes on Wednesday but
usually on Thursday you see the midweek
reversal back into the weekend range
okay uh another was pointing towards
this Asian pump I think we'll eventually
retrace this uh this candle here it
might take a few more days okay because
we're talking if not today about
pretty much one much of a drop is this
we'll be talking if not
about five percent drop what happened
today it could well I mean it's more
likely that we you know take more days
to get there but it's likely that we go
again to this we can range based on this
pattern okay and that would be another
way to 25 900.
and 25 700 okay something like that
that is destiny that I'm that I'm hoping
for today right and then maybe on Friday
you could either continue going lower or
the most likely thing is either a little
little little poop
or sideways
right so that's what I'm expecting to
happen basically in the next 24 hours so
far you know or plan for the week has
been I would say uh pretty much on point
something that you know it gives me
confidence to believe that today we
might see that meet with reversal again
am I I'm gonna be completely wrong but
that's how I play the markets okay it's
based on possibilities
every trade setup every trade that you
take
is based on possibilities what is more
likely this is more likely that this
happens or that that happens okay and
that's why I play the market so under my
understanding it's more likely that
today we'd see the midweek reversal okay
so that's what I'm expecting a drop
today in the crypto market today we got
lots of news announcements we go right
now we're gonna have in a couple of
hours the European Central Bank interest
rate Edition
we're also gonna get PPI data in the US
retail sales and unemployment claim so
it's going to be
a massive day but if I'm not wrong I
think after 1 pm UTC time
the market should be settled I think
that by then we would have uh heard all
these news announcements okay and then
the New York session is going to absorb
all the information and then trade
accordingly so you know I would suggest
to keep an eye on that data that's going
to come out because if it's negative for
Bitcoin or if it's positive for the
dollar
all right then this hasn't been higher
things to play out
right so that's what I'm looking for
today we can rent Monday's first move
weak strength midweek reversal and then
maybe on Friday either sideways all a
little little pump right so that's
pretty much everything regarding with
Bitcoin now I would like to get my
prediction back there it is and this is
what I'm gonna keep an eye on okay this
projection is still valid
maybe again we could add usually a tiny
bit more like this
all right
but something like this this one is a
zone that I want to make a business in
right so now let's go to High block
Capital but I'm sure when I still see
those liquidations there let's go there
capital and you can see the daily title
eight billion dollars worth of long
liquidations okay in yesterday's video I
think we were around four or five
billion dollars and I was telling you
will probably gonna get to 10 billions
and then drop so far we are eight okay
if they set a stop hunt right before the
New York session to hit you know right
below 27k
then that is likely to be 10 billion
dollars and then you can see that drop
and look at these liquidations here look
at the spikes
of liquidity here at the right of the
chart right you go there uh 25 700 you
got 204 million dollars worth of long
liquidations
but you also got here at 25 488 a lot of
liquidations and all the way to 25 200
okay that's basically the Asian pump so
I mean the liquidity
I mean if I if I look at this
you know there are more Traders position
or long than on short so that means that
the long positions are at a risk
you know theoretically
eight million dollars right now
and the liquidity is took downside so
this is not a place where I would like
to open lungs okay it's as simple as
that
now let's go to the acquisition hit map
seven days time frame
let's see what we got here
look at these guys I mean it's it's not
a coincidence come on this can't be a
coincidence look at that week okay we'll
then hit these liquidations then the
liquidity
increased and it happens again here
all right and the liquidity increased we
didn't heat it for you know a hundred
dollars why
because the market maker wants to
increase the liquidations here so when
they expect price up to the zone
they're gonna hit more liquidations that
they could have done previously okay so
the movies will be more efficient so you
can even see this yellow bar
getting brighter after yesterday Spike
up
all right
so
um quite interesting sum between 26 650
and 26 800 now if you go to the 12 first
time frame I haven't checked this today
all right quite interesting you can see
the liquidity over there still okay 26
600 and 26 650 so again
even this time from Stadium the
liquidity is still present over there
one more time frame
the distances are you know too far away
literally we are two thousand dollars
away from this Zone and almost three
thousand well three thousand dollars
away from this so now it's not giving me
much information we're too distant from
those two zones and a three months time
frame
what I see here is you know what we've
talked previously look at that week
didn't hit this Zone the liquidity
increases they set price back down again
on Monday but they don't hit distance
the liquidity increases now we go not
only one zero bar like we did here now
we got three one two three there is a
lot of Liquidations in this zone so
that's what I think that in the midterm
price is set to go down
okay of course you know as a day trade
I'm taking advantage of this little
intraday moves
but in the bigger picture price should
still head down okay and hate these
Liquidations in the higher time frame so
that's what I think for Bitcoin now
before I finish this video I want to
remind you that this campaign that I'm
doing with bin cakes one of the top
exchanges and one of the few ones that
doesn't require kyc it finishes on
Friday so we only have today and
tomorrow okay and basically it's
important you register using the
referral link you deposit fifty dollars
and keep it there for at least three
days and then you're gonna get fifty
dollars for free all right so you put 50
you get 50. simple
um you also have some other rewards for
example trading over five thousand
dollars in trading volume including
leverage so it's not as much
you get a hundred dollar bonus okay and
of course uh active Traders using my
referral links are gonna get access to
the indicator that I'm working on that
it's going to highlight the wigs the
liquidity pools trading sessions Etc and
also students from the course that one
it's been currently for a couple of
months
um so that's pretty much everything guys
thank you so much for your support
and for watching the video and I'll see
you soon